hello yeah so how are you coping in
isolation are you staying with your
parents right now and your
your family yeah it's fully we've fully
reverted back
i am 15 again um in my bedroom
like fully in my childhood bedroom with
my sisters everyone's home
like i'm sitting in my room eating pasta
and being like mom i'm busy like i'm on
on canadian okay sorry
like it's oh my god it's literally like
a reality tv show it's so funny
but you're secretly loving it you're
loving it right yeah 100
like people are making me food and i'm
like oh like my sister brings me lunch
in bed and i'm like this is quite good
like am i gonna leave this oh i love
that
yeah i'm loving it too i'm here home
with my kids and we're chilling and
having a good time
and they're healthy i'm healthy so life
is good right it's always
absolutely good yeah and we have so much
to celebrate with you because sad girls
summer is such a catchy
beautiful song and it's resonating with
so many people especially
young girls what does that mean for you
as as an artist to see that your
your words are actually helping others
yes it's insane it's like the best thing
i think
yeah we all you know write songs just in
small rooms
you know i wrote it with like three of
my really close friends and you never
really think about
everybody else listening to it in their
rooms like with their friends
and i think this song especially is so
fun because
it is such a girl gang vibe and i just
love i love
the idea that you know once social
listening maybe you know let's up a bit
there's going to be all these girl gangs
across the world all getting ready like
living their best lives
at all like i tweeted last night
absolute chaos i could cause if you act
if everyone actually passed their phone
to the right
and texted their friends ex-boyfriends i
was like
oh my god the anarchy the actual anarchy
that i could cause but it's so fun and
it's so amazing to see everyone
like i feel like it's really it's like
super empowering and it's really fun
seeing everybody
feeling themselves and being like yes
you know what yeah
let it go so you're you've passed the
your phone to the right
and texted the next goodbye you have
done that
i mean i haven't done it i i am advising
i'm not saying i'm gonna do i don't
practice my preaching
i definitely oh i have some friends
absolutely i have some friends but i'm
gonna get in the room and be like give
me your phone
like i've definitely oh yeah you texted
goodbye
instead of calling them you're texting
them well i i currently have a friend
um who i'm being every day i text her
and tell her to break up with her
boyfriend because i think they should
break up
so every day i'm just lifting the
stagger so i'm like i need to
and this video is so beautiful it is so
empowering
it's so beautiful to see all these girls
come together of diversity so how did
you connect it with everybody to be part
of it
well loads of them are just my friends
um my sister's in it
and then my friend who i live with is in
it
and then my friend abby who i actually
met in l.a and she lives in indonesia
she's in it um and so yeah
most of them are just my friends and
then a couple of them are just like cool
girls that i saw on instagram and i just
really liked that look and i was like
they would be sick in it too um and it
was just really a case of
just i was just messaging everyone being
like can you please be in my video
um you can just eat snacks on camera and
everyone luckily agreed
and then yeah everyone was just the me
and the directors worked together and
the directors would just facetime
everybody individually
and ask them to like hate boys for half
an hour
and we collated it i love you i love you
i need to hang out with you when i'm in
england absolutely
okay i'm mad at you i love canada
when you saw the video for the first
time all coming together
what did that mean to you to be able to
see
your girlfriends coming together and
creating that is so powerful
oh i loved it it was so fun seeing it
coming together because i was really
involved like i
made like such a concise plans and i had
such a
concise vision um but also i only
obviously what's funny is i only saw my
part and my sister
are filming of the video so i hadn't
seen anybody else's bits
because they were all filmed separately
so it's so fun to get to see
it's like an edit of everyone and i just
had no idea like all of my friends
dark horses like coming through with all
these sassy poses and i was like
you yeah really um but yeah it was so
fun to see it come
and you created a tick tock dance for
this song
yes you came up with the moves
i i would like to say i i helped my
friend
dominique is a dancer and she did it
with me
um and i'm not a dancer we actually
filmed some good behind the scenes of
her trying to teach me
like how to body roll and stuff which i
will maybe put on the internet one day
if i lose all sound respect
but um i know i would like i definitely
helped you know the
the general the vibe to the vibe but she
did a lot of work
yeah and there's so much other things to
celebrate your birthday just passed and
you're a twin
i mean did you get a chat i guess
because you're home now you get to
celebrate together right
yeah that was the best day actually we
spent all of our childhoods being like
oh it sucks having a birthday together
and then we became adults we were like
this is so good it's just like a
ready-made party
um and yeah so we did we did a live
stream where we made cocktails
um and that was uh chaotic
um but great i'm actually we're both now
professional cocktail makers and my
sister
had one too many porn style martinis and
may have thrown up in her bed
but we move we move
you know when you as an artist when you
create music or you create whatever it
is
you always have that one person and you
kind of want their approval you want him
to
like what you do is that your sister
when you create new music do you go to
your sister and say
what do you think do you like it um
i definitely want her approval because i
feel like she's very savage so
it's good if she likes it i know it's
good um good
yeah but at the same time you know i
don't i don't like to trust
her too much because she will she's just
very yeah she's very savage like my
first ever song was called playstore
made
and she heard it and she was like it
just smells like ed sheeran but not as
good
i was like right but no i do definitely
want her free goals
yeah i love that yeah because each that
means she did like it so it's just
right yeah yeah honestly is the best
policy
yeah and you started creating me music
when you were very young you were nine
years old when you started creating
lyrics
do you remember what you started talking
about in your lyrics at that
that age oh yeah 100 i wrote a song when
i was nine uh called sang castles
about sand and you would think there
wasn't much to say about sam but
apparently there was
i also actually wrote down in this
notebook i found from 2009 which is how
i know i was nine
i wrote down all the lyrics uh to the
sugar babes about you now
and then i went around school and tried
to tell everyone that i wrote the sugar
vapes about you now
which which was a very it was a
see-through lie
but i was a i was an entrepreneurial
nine-year-old
yeah how would you just describe your
music some people say it's folks some
people say it's pop
how do you define it um
i would say it's
or organic girl pop
um but i would go with anything i think
i'm like big on storytelling and i am
rooted in the very like singer
songwriter folk that's like a lot of my
beginnings i was actually listening to a
lot of country music so there's probably
some of that in there as well
um but then i love my pop music at the
same time so probably a mix of
it just mix up everything together uh
and you one of the things i noticed with
your lyrics are they're very personal
and you go for it and you talk about
your own experiences does that make you
worried
in any way going forward i mean it
really depends on the song you know it
depends if yeah
if you're savaging someone uh who will
listen to the song
but no i think in general i always try
and
make sure that i'm saying enough that it
will
you know emote with people and connect
people but not too much
that i'm ruining my own life so it's a
healthy balance but no i think
i think it's all right i think i've told
it pretty okay so far
that's good and you you're getting
support by someone named taylor swift
you know someone who tweeted you
i mean uh let's let's talk about that
moment
i mean i'm even sweating just thinking
about it so
she supported you she's out there and
she knows who you are oh my god
how did it happen how did you feel break
it down
okay i mean this is the this was the
best moment of my life
um because i've been a taylor swift fan
since i was literally like 10 years old
um and i was out at the shops with my
sister and i came home
and i posted this cover of enchanted the
night before because i was doing this
thing called bed covers the beginning of
quarantine where i post a copper every
night
um and i posted and i went to the shops
and i came back and my
phone just blown up and someone was like
taylor's
tweeted you and i swear my blood ran
cold like i've never felt
so many emotions in my entire life and
then i saw it and i just screamed and i
ran into my sister's room and we both
just screamed
um and then i replied something really
fangirly and i just paced around my
house like half an hour like i just
couldn't do anything
um and then i calmed down a bit and then
i realized that i peaked
and that was that but it's i mean yeah
i'm her i'm the biggest tablespoon fan
everybody knows that
so it was so special and it's like still
so bizarre that she's seen my face
like it's too much it's too much so have
you met her yet
no no i think if she was in a room with
me i'd i'd just like
nod and walk out because i wouldn't be
able to cope with it so you don't know
what you're going to say to her if you
meet her mate you're going to meet her
one day soon i'm sure
gosh what would you feel right i don't
know you have to
you have to be prepared you gotta be
focused oh god i know you're stressing
me out
okay i'm gonna go for bed i'm gonna go
and be like
wow canadian weekly really really turn
it no okay i really do need to make a
plan
because i'm planning on just like
running with the improv but you're right
that's and that's a terrible idea
to make up this plan yeah you're going
to be always ready
i have like an escape route on my phone
just like hey taylor
sorry just one second are you
consistently writing is that what you're
doing right now
yeah i'm really consistently writing
i've done a lot of stuff uh on my own
obviously in quarantine which has been
really fun because that's how i started
out
so it's been really cool to go back to
basics and
yeah i've been writing loads of songs um
i actually need to record them i'll
probably do that after this
um i've just got like a little recording
studio in my bedroom
so yeah but i've been really productive
actually it's been that's been really
good
what is success for you how do you
define that
oh um
i think success is uh
playing songs that you wrote and that
you love
to rooms of people that also love them
and seeing those rooms
increase in numbers but seeing
like the the passion and the energy in
the room stay the same
i think i think that success when you
look
to the future and success is going and
it's happening where do you see yourself
in five years where do you want to be
oh that's such a good question um i want
to be
i mean i hope we're all touring again
i'd love to be
on some big world tour um with all of my
best friends that i tour with
um i'd love to be in like canada like
i'd like
this time i'd love to be in canada right
now like about to play a show
had some sushi or something just
chilling backstage with all the bands
like preparing ready to go on stage
that's what you want to do and me taylor
swift don't forget you're supposed to
put that
yeah yeah you're opening for a taylor
swift like that
exactly that's what's going to happen so
we're going to connect again in five
years and you're gonna tell me
that's what's gonna happen and we'll be
talking to taylor swift and all that's
gonna
be interesting
you are adorable and i i don't want to
take you away from your parents go have
your dinner uh say hi to your parents
and uh congratulations to you and all
your success the song is
absolutely amazing and yes thank you so
much thank you so much
thank you this has been so fun
you